hello and welcome to the video playing
machete from the shelf no probably not
looks a bit like a machete from a
distance or it isn't but anyway so the
panko gambit okay another little bit of
fan of this line oh it for bed this is a
pretty strange way of playing with white
which doesn't make it um bad I'm just
saying always felt that why does giving
black most of the fun it is complicated
though absolutely so a takes before now
is the most them it is what usually
happens okay you should therefore looks
a bit surprising I mean what has to be
careful here strategically speaking his
position sucks totally with the pollen
f3 of the dark squares a week he has no
development and so on and he has to be
quite carefully and not to getting
killed quickly so let's see what happens
here 96 is the most natural
so I will definitely be okay if I just
develop I just wonder if i can i can
somehow refuse this stuff definitely
close but I came I just make a couple of
normals that's not the reputation maybe
there was one maybe that wasn't but I've
lost often enough but trying to refute
bed openings and then a lost on time
because it was bad but not so bad okay
so I'll go here and now try to get rid
of the night on before that his best
piece carling she takes Queen takes I've
got c4 coming Luke the aid and so on he
Celeste this weekend situation with the
airport maybe he will play something
else here no okay yah hoopty eight looks
very normal fee for something that I
would like to get in okay let's just go
to create if I go b3 here where do you
go I might take him not a big fan of
moving upon their to to cover this but
maybe after
Jeff the worst is definitely over friend
in the opening maybe I had some
improvement okay
cuff him interesting stuff going on hmm
i don't know i might have these three
and rookie to hear last ok now the Queen
can go over them Bishop g5 doesn't quite
work looks pretty strange to play and
put it on b3 really strange I mean this
is this is a move i mean i can't play
this move right let's look at a 4 didn't
see that didn't see that
okay I can play Bishop b3 though wasn't
planned which works as Bishop 25 and all
kinds of stuff so no here it takes me
seven huh wow wow wow wow well cable um
I know okay let's let's play it and then
and then see x is equal him
don't see something great for what you
can take an idea
[Music]
happy three I just wondered can I take
it I don't see why I cannot let's just
keep the stuff okay seat we will take
time learning check check check check
check check check that's not dammit rook
takes h2 is made daughter check
checkmate okay I'm kind of curious also
if I miss something earlier on because I
think why jack is played this opening
quite badly I don't think that stuff
like that is good I mean he and I must
have something not something like
winning but more than I got the engine
suggest age five exactly thought about
that but it just sell to our lenders to
me this is what I did and all three also
saw that far this is interesting though
this seems to be good I'm cause of this
trick okay now we're getting there now
if you have to check with a look then
this is getting interesting i can put
something on before even though we
should be seven is given okay engine
gives me an advantage but nothing
overwhelming yeah maybe i should have
taken on a three this this isn't super
grade
should be fine thought you can take but
this is actually not that grade I've got
these three and rudi two coming they're
tough you just have to sometimes go go
with a move TI m equal according to the
engine that's possible but this is just
like gin trade it down to something
equal yeah yeah i was expecting these
three actually i will be 5 i'm not even
having this ok somehow here I am after
this I'm getting getting somewhere check
and with the with the time ticking down
it was the clothes trick him I hadn't
made it to hahahaha Oh lots of the
single lead now is just happy to get
that hon it didn't look any further what
it is winning check check check yeah
dude this made our spotters not like we
can computer gives like a million fire
but I spotted that this wins and has
made in mating patterns going for it ok
guys thanks for watching